actors can try for years to land a
decent role and even when they do it's
no guarantee of success those who
managed to make it big often say the
same thing they were in the right place
at the right time have a look at the
auditions that changed everything for
these actors Daisy Ridley playing ray in
Star Wars The Force awakens catapulted
Daisy Ridley onto the ælis hundreds of
young actresses audition for the part
including established stars like Chloe
grace Moretz and Oscar nominee Saoirse
Ronan
so when Disney announced the casting of
a young British actress named Daisy
Ridley Hollywood let out a collective
exclamation of poo prior to her Star
Wars audition Ridley had limited
exposure to an international audience
appearing mostly in British films and
television but her audition for the
force awakens changed everything for her
screen-test Ridley had to perform a
scene in which her character is tortured
by the film's villain kylo Ren when we
brought her in I asked her to do this
one scene for this torture scene very
sort of intense and she just blew my
mind she's reaching this depth of
struggle and tears are streaming down
her face I thought this is unbelievable
director JJ Abrams and producer Kathleen
Kennedy were impressed and Ridley became
one of the first actors cast in the film
which unsurprisingly went on to become
the highest-grossing movie of 2015
thanks of course to the force that's not
how the force works Hugh Jackman the
original x-men in 2000 introduced the
world to Hugh Jackman and the actor has
relished his a-list status ever since
prior to playing Wolverine Jackman had
mostly worked on the Australian stage
performing in musicals like Oklahoma and
Sunset Boulevard that all changed when a
casting director eyed him to play the
hairy clawed mutant though his initial
audition was very low key for the
Berserker I'm not like you all right
you're just a normal everyday Claude
listen kid about the only thing you've
done to endear yourself to me is to get
me into a fight so listen to me shut up
director Bryan Singer loved Jackman's
audition but Fox studio executives
weren't convinced and wanted a bigger
name initially casting the grey Scott in
the part when Scott had to decline the
role due to scheduling conflicts singer
turned back to Jackman giving him a
screen test
actress Anna Paquin this time he won the
role despite his wife's objections I'd
like to say it was my business plan it
was a complete fluke
dad said you shouldn't do it he thought
it was a terrible idea to devolver him
the only time in 20 years she's been
wrong please and you feel free to edit
that bit out
Harrison Ford it's hard to imagine now
but Harrison Ford had a difficult time
in Hollywood after relocating from his
native state of Wisconsin he initially
managed to secure small TV roles and a
few bit parts and films but for 10 years
he continued to struggle financially
supplementing his income by working as a
stagehand and carpenter that's where
Ford caught the attention of casting
director Fred Roos who recommended him
for American Graffiti directed by George
Lucas despite the film's success Ford
still struggle to find roles years later
an actor scheduled to read the role for
Star Wars as resident space scoundrel
han Solo
failed to show up for his read Scotty
Stoney like the sound of that George
Lucas contacted Ford to come in while
actresses tested for the female lead the
directors saw something special in Ford
and asked him for his own audition well
I'm not going to take an impossible
chase across the galaxy
I was paid to bring you here now you're
here give me my other five thousand then
I'll be on my way you're on your own I'm
on my own I'll let you off on the
nearest system also reading for the role
of Han Solo a young Kurt Russell
Sigourney Weaver though it would be
years before she impressed audiences
with her vocal abilities what a lovely
scene boy she must have Sigourney Weaver
began her career off-broadway having
graduated from Yale's drama program
after kind of appearing in a small very
small role in Woody Allen's hit Annie
Hall a casting director suggested Weaver
to director Ridley Scott who was casting
a new science fiction film called alien
I'll get off your back soon is 12 module
is fixed
put down your beer and and use both of
them maybe then you get it done Scott
had trouble deciding between Weaver and
a friend and co-star of hers meryl
streep since both had tested for the
part he invited several women from the
production office to view the two screen
tests and the women immediately said
Weaver as their favorite alien would
become an international sensation
spawning a number of sequels and making
Weaver a star three Oscar nominations
later it's safe to say Scott made a good
choice with Weaver Christopher Reeve
he's the most iconic superhero in the
world so casting Superman in his first
big full-color theatrical outing was a
pretty big deal for producers Elia and
Alexander Salkin after hiring director
Richard Donner to helm the production
the creative team auditioned established
stars like James Caan and Paul Newman
and even then unknown body builder
Arnold Schwarzenegger casting director
Lynn style master suggested a young
actor named Christopher Reeve who'd
studied drama at the esteemed Julliard
School and had a number of stage credits
to his name Donner and the Salk uns
first resisted casting Reeve deeming him
too thin
still at the insistence of stall master
Donner allowed Reeve to do a screen test
well I come from a planet in the Zeno
galaxy it's a place called Krypton
Krypton with a CR y no no actually it's
Krypton with a kr Y the director would
later recall that when he saw Reeve
dressed in the full Superman costume
jump onto the screen for the first time
he knew he found his Superman Reeve
would go on to play the role in three
subsequent sequels becoming a cultural
icon along the way Gabourey Sidibe the
1996 novel push had become something of
a cult sensation by 2009 when film
director Lee Daniels selected it as his
next film project the story about an
abused teenage girl attracted acclaim as
well as criticism for its raw dark
themes casting the right person in the
lead role was vital as most of the drama
the story would follow the shoulders of
the leading actress the film which was
retitled precious offered an open call
for actresses to audition regardless of
experience Gabourey Sidibe heard about
the audition but she'd never acted on
screen before fortunately Sidibe gave a
stunning audition beating
300 other girls what but I'm crowded in
the giant Rhythm City they filmed the
movie and only a few weeks but precious
would go on to become a lasting critical
and commercial sensation earning her a
Best Actress Academy Award nomination
Daniel Radcliffe the Harry Potter book
series was already a pop-culture
phenomenon by the Time Warner Brothers
won the rights to produce film
adaptations of the series first four
books in 1998 the series would face one
main logistical problem with each book
set a year apart all of the films would
need to be filmed in rapid succession so
that their child actors would age
naturally an 11 year old actor named
Daniel Radcliffe attracted the attention
of producer David Heyman Radcliffe had
acted in just a couple of British
television productions before scoring
his audition for Harry Potter and had to
audition several times over a period of
eight months before his final screen
test not to track an egg so Gladys why
did you get it Hagrid must cost you a
fortune
JK Rowling gave her approval and just
like that Radcliffe was the face of a
blockbuster franchise and then he'd go
on to play a farting corpse
no points for gryffindor on that one
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to